for
[Silence]
Miss ald
m
[Silence]
We are continuing
in we took a bit of a detour to add in
some parts
that did not focus
on as we mentioned
before as its name
suggests is a book written about the
prophet sallallah Al
Provisions for the
Hereafter taken from
the
guidance
of the best
of individuals or the best of
servants to
Allah and that is
that the idea of the book is
primarily everything having to do with
him his names his attributes his
descriptions
Etc and part of that is
listing his miracles that he
performed and we filled some of that in
from one of the origins one of the
references of this book which
is
for these are one of the this is one of
the books
that referenced in his compilation of Z
when writing this book and so we
referred to that and mentioned with a
bit of
detail the physical descriptions of the
Prophet
Sall and
also his
character and also his
miracles and now we return
to we have
reached
therein to just after hij we discussed
hij we discussed his arrival to
Medina building his
Masjid and now we
discuss the early
stages of preparation for combat when he
was allowed and they the Muslims were
allowed in their new state to begin to
De defend
themselves and treat other tribes and
other
regions
as friends or foes allies or
enemies and to be able to have the
weight of their own State and their own
governance
Etc and so with having a sovereign state
there comes a need to defend it there
comes the threat of invasion there
comes all of these things and
so these are the early stages when the
prophet Sall wasam Was preparing the
companions to defend themselves which
we'll discuss
[Silence]
of
Al
[Silence]
sh
Allah subhah
[Silence]
Sur
andr
[Silence]
for for
We are
continuing and going into the phase we
are continuing from when he made hij
am we
discussed building the first
Masjid we
discussed when he made
the
Companions and he kind of grafted the M
into
the and he did this what is
called which means he would take one
person that had made hij and he would
pair him with one person who was from
Medina and he paired them up in this way
to the point that their relationship was
to be so complete so full so
entire that they would even at one
point the m and the ANSI the one who
migrated and the one who received in
Medina they would be so entwined with
each other and so close that they would
actually inherit from one
another and this is as we know in Allah
subhanahu waala's law this is
for this is strictly
for relatives strictly for family
members with familial ties specifically
through Blood Ties however this
was to drive home the
seriousness
of the ansar receiving the muaj of the
muajin integrating themselves entirely
into the world and the culture of the
ansar to the point where they were
indistinguishable after this they
started to have a state
they now had a place called Medina it is
referred to as
Medina short for
Med short for The
Messengers City or
also it's also referred to as the
lighted
city which means that when the prophet
sallallah wasam arrived at that City due
to his presence and the presence of his
companions there the city itself became
illuminated it was not Illuminating it
became illuminated by the presence of
its citizenry starting with the prophet
sallai wasam and
so now they have a city together we have
the the Believers the Muslims we have
the polytheus the Arab polytheus of
Medina and then we have the Jews of
Medina so we have three types of people
three factions or religions that were
there in Medina at this
time and so there were also influences
from the outside just any sovereign
state when a state becomes Sovereign and
is founded it will have enemies and it
will have
allies and it now possesses one of
the greatest attributes of a sovereign
state a free state is that it has the
ability and the right to defend
itself right and so these are the
beginning
stages of that
defense that occurred with the prophet
sallam here in the early days in Medina
when he arrived at Medina tells us and
he established himself
there Allah subhanahu
Waal surrounded him with
Believers and he subhanahu waala
prevented the many attempts on his life
and the many attempts on his
da Allah
gave him the
Companions and he United their hearts
even though they had previous grudges
before
Islam
and the ANS who were the original
inhabitants of Medina the
original people that lived in Medina
they were later
called meaning the victors The Defenders
why because they gave victory to the
prophet s. wasam and they protected him
from those hostile
forces that meant him
harm when we say that there were three
groups it's more accurate to probably
say that there were four
groups so when the prophet
Sall arrived at
Medina there were four main groups
groups and in order to understand the
Quran properly and understand its
context and the context of each of its
verses it's important to understand
these four groups this
Dynamic we had the Believers the
Muslims we had those who pretended to
become Muslim now we haven't arrived at
that Junction
yet because the Hypocrites known as the
MF they are the ones who pledged
allegiance to the prophet sallallah
wasam but in reality were attempting to
sabotage him and his companions from the
beginning From
Within These Hypocrites these
MF they really became prominent or
they they became a
Thing Once the Battle of Badr happened
because no one expected the Battle of
Badr to go the way it
did everyone expected that the prophet
sallallahu alai and his companions would
just be completely put
out by the Battle of bad they were
attacked suddenly
very
unexpectedly and everyone expected that
he and his companions would be martyred
would be killed during that battle and
things would go back in the Arab
peninsula they were
before so when the Muslims were given
victory in their first major victory in
the Battle of
B this now became a turning point many
people entered into Islam and many
people entered into
Islam pretending to have accepted
Islam when really it was a politic
thing to do these are the people now
coming up and just as anything that
becomes prominent or anything that gains
traction people will try to latch on to
it and use it for their own benefit
so we will discuss that then we had the
people who remained as polytheists they
remained as you know upon the
religion of their forefathers just like
in Mecca they had Idols that they
worshiped and then we had the fourth
group or faction which was the group of
the Jews three Jewish tribes that were
in Medina at the time and we discussed
this previously so verses of the Quran
they are
revealed in Medina addressing these four
main groups of
people and there are a lot of gray areas
and a lot of
gradation between those groups
which we will come to
insh once the prophet
s established himself there in Medina
and Allah subhah waala surrounded him
with his most trustworthy and upright
Companions
and all Muslims were treated alike as a
matter of fact all citizens of Medina
if you will
governments and and things were not set
up the way they are today in modern
times but there were those who had
allegiance to the prophet sallallah alai
wasam and his companions and with that
Allegiance came certain rights they
didn't have to become
Muslim but they did have to be on
time of treaty and keep peace and uphold
certain ends of a so that they not be
viewed as enemies and part of that is
that if Medina were to be under siege or
there were to be some they would have to
fight alongside the Muslims to defend
their
land and
so the rest of the Arab
peninsula the different tribes and
different regions and different they all
began to conspire against the prophet
sallallah alai was
the problem in Mecca was very different
it was him and a few Companions and he
was calling to Islam mainly during the
times of
Hajj they made it unbearable for him and
his companions they migrated to Medina
and
now what the PE people of quray the
polytheists the idolators of that
time what they tried to the the more
they tried to extinguish this Flame the
brighter it got and the more it spread
which is the
exact description of the truth this is
how the truth is it cannot be fully
extinguished it can be covered up it can
be hidden it can be you know entwined
and laced with lies but at the end of
the day the truth is something that
cannot be erased fully from the
earth and so they began to have
enemies enemies of the Prophet sallallah
alam's State and his companions and the
rest of the Arab peninsula those tribes
they saw everyone in Medina as being
pretty much equal they
all have basically waged war against
them This Is How They View viewed it and
so Allah subhanahu waala gave
permission
to defend themselves for the
companions to take up arms and defend
their state defend their profit
defend their religion defend their
Liberty to worship Allah alone without
any Partners this began with the 39th
verse
of in the 39th verse of Allah subhanahu
waala tells us that which translates
to and it
is been made permissible for those
who are fought
against to meaning to fight to fight
back and defend themselves being that
they have been oppressed and
transgressed against and indeed Allah is
ever able
to give them Victory this verse in
Surah is the first verse revealed
regarding permission to take up arms and
to
fight this verse is in a
chapter is a mechan
chapter it's a chapter of the Quran
Quran revealed in
Mecca
and the verses of the Quran revealed in
Mecca or the chapters revealed in
Mecca they have a very particular
tone they have a very particular
climate they have a very
particular set of rules and even
narrative and for those who studi the
Quran mechan verses
and Med verses those revealed before hij
those revealed after Hijra they're very
distinguishable because they have two
completely different
tones and the reason for that is the
audience is
different before Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala was addressing the Muslims as a
minority amongst the majority of
hostile idolators
and then the tone changed to a majority
of Believers majority of Muslims amongst
whom a minority of idolators and other
religions lived amongst and so the tone
is very
different mentions this verse inah that
we just mentioned and he says this was
the first verse revealed
regarding
permitting them to take up arms and Def
defend thems and some of the scholars
have mentioned that this verse was
revealed in
Mecca where Allah subhanahu wa taala
says it has been made
permissible for those who have been
fought
against to defend
themselves to defend themselves from
violence with
violence being that they have been
transgressed against and indeed Allah is
ever able to
give them Victory to grant them Victory
some of the scholars say this verse was
revealed in
Mecca and the reason they say that is
because this chapter is considered to be
a mecan chapter meaning revealed before
hij however says this is
incorrect this verse was revealed in
Medina and this verse was revealed
regarding the junction that we are we
have arrived at here in the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam story and he
mentions a number of reasons for that
it's very important and the scholars of
Islam went through great pains to
distinguish which general era each verse
of the Quran was revealed in was it
before hij or after
hij what was revealed before his
migration to Medina they referred to is
mechin this is a mechin chapter and what
was revealed after his migration they
refer this refer to this as a
medin medini reference to Medina
chapter regardless of the physical place
it was revealed this is more of a
reference this categorization is more of
a reference to the era than it is to the
place but understanding where and when
and what under what circumstances
chapters or verses of the Quran were
revealed this is incredibly important
and key to gaining deeper insight into
the meanings of the verses when you read
the verses of the Quran they're clear
there is a Clarity to them that every
person reading them no matter what
language they read them in they will
understand but there is also a depth to
these verses
every verse of the Quran which can only
be completely understood entirely and
all of its nuances
highlighted by way of gathering
information as to where when why how
these verses were revealed to the
prophet sallallah alai wasallam to the
point that some Scholars have written
entire books on this
subject and and they have even made
distinctions in verses which verses were
revealed in summer which which verses
were revealed in Winter which verses
were revealed in the daytime which
verses were revealed at nighttime which
verses were revealed to him while he was
laying down which verses were revealed
to him while he was walking which verses
were revealed to him while he was
writing and this all gives us deeper
context and gives us
greater highlights of the nuances of
each of these verses so this verse was
revealed in Mecca some Scholars say it
was Reve this verse was revealed in
Medina some Scholars say it was revealed
in Mecca and says this is incorrect it
was not revealed in Mecca and that is
due to a number of reasons we will
mention these numbers these reasons
because I think that it's important for
us
to ponder upon everything mentions
especially with regards to the Quran
[Silence]
and
s
[Silence]
subhah Waal
qu
[Silence]
be
Quan
[Silence]
for
m al if Lam m al if Lam me for
[Silence]
qu
s
[Silence]
am
Fe
[Silence]
it's important for us to know in with
in briefly
that the Quran its verses have been
revealed and the order that that those
verses are in is part of the
Revelation meaning if we were to say the
verses of the Quran as they are
today are these verses 1 2 3 4 are these
verses in this
order because the prophet s.
wasam received
them and was told to place them in this
order
from Allah or was this something that
the
companions when they compiled the Quran
they
decided it's best we put these verses in
this order the answer is is that the
scholars agree that the order of the
verses of the Quran is from Allah
subhanahu waala the difference of
opinion is the order of the
chapters are the chapters in this order
meaning starting
with is the Quran in this order is this
from Allah or is this something that the
companions kind of worked out and that's
part of their
opinion and the correct opinion is that
everything is from Allah the Quran is
from Allah the order of it verses is
from Allah and the Order of its chapters
is from
Allah why do we say that we say that for
a number of reasons but the most
important is that the order of the
chapters of the
Quran is their
meaning understood from the order of the
chapters so for instance if I were to be
speaking
right and I had four or five things to
discuss and I placed these four or five
things in a particular
order when I transition and segue from
one topic to the
next is there not some meaning to be
derived from that meaning there's a
reason why I I put them in this
order there's a meaning behind it
there's something that is implied but
it's not
said that meaning is part of the
Quran and so the order of the chapters
of the
Quran
are from Allah subhanahu waala when we
first open the Quran and we see the
first chapter
ofah what do we understand from the
Quran beginning with F we understand
that this is the primary chapter of the
Quran all other chapters of the Quran
are to be
understood under the light
of that is correct and that is what
you're supposed to understand when you
first open the Quran you
find you read these verses and then you
continue to read the remainder of the
Quran when you transition from
toah Allah subhah waala says guide us
the straight path the path of Those whom
you
are whom Your Grace is upon not Those
whom your anger is upon nor those who
have gone
astray then he moves
in this Quran is guidance for those who
are righteous those who and he starts to
list different aspects of the believer
is this not an explanation expounding
upon the meanings we just read in yes
absolutely and that's how the Quran is
supposed to be
understood and so it
is very weak
opinion that the vers the chapters of
the Quran are
not part of the Quran the order of the
chapters are part of the quran's
meanings just the order of the
verses are part of the quran's
meanings what those meanings are they're
implied and not every scholar is going
to understand every single meaning the
Quran is too expansive for any one
mind to
completely to completely grasp all of
its nuances and notice all of its detail
except for the prophet Muhammad Sall
alai wasallam
however it's important for us to know
that when
we when
we take that which is revealed in Mecca
before hij and that which is revealed
after hij this is a
generalization this is not
absolute it doesn't mean that absolutely
every single
verse in this particular chapter if that
chapter is mecki that every verse was
revealed before Hijra not necessarily
there are exceptions to that
rule and
Surah is one of the chapters of the
Quran which has that exception in
it is a chapter that has verses that
were revealed in Mecca
definitely and it has verses that were
revealed in Medina definitely and they
is an amalgamation of mechan and medini
chapters and that's very deliberate and
it's very
clear but this verse that we're
discussing the 39th verse of
Surah it is a verse that was revealed in
Medina but it's found in a predominantly
mechan chapter when we say a chapter is
mechin or Medi we are saying the
framework for this chapter
chapter began in
Mecca but some of it may have been
concluded in Medina and then he goes on
to mention some of the reasons for this
and the most prominent of those reasons
why for sure this 39th verse of Surah we
are certain was revealed in me revealed
in Medina is because it
mentions physical violence or it
eludes to it if you will it authorizes
that the Muslims and the companions that
they defend themselves physically and
this was only allowed after Hijra this
was only allowed in Medina this was
never allowed in
Mecca and we will stop there for this
evening
[Silence]
abbar